a pocos días del primer año de la guerra
en Ucrania los 193 países miembros de la
ONU se reúnen en la asamblea general
para discutir sobre una resolución que
pide al cese hostilidades y subraye la
necesidad de lograr lo antes posible la
paz entre kiev y Moscú la resolución no
es vinculante por lo que su peso es
exclusivamente político la postura del
secretario general de la ONU Antonio
Gutiérrez es Clara
el año de la invasión de Rusia Ucrania
es un hito sombrío para el pueblo
ucraniano y para la comunidad
internacional
es la invasión es una afrenta a nuestra
conciencia colectiva
es una violación de la carta de las
Naciones Unidas y el derecho
internacional para Rusia las
declaraciones de Gutiérrez y la
realización de unas sesión especial
demuestran en declaraciones de gobierno
ruso el deseo de occidente por acabar
con Rusia de forma estratégica
en su deseo de infligir una derrota a
Rusia De cualquier manera posible no
solo pueden sacrificar a Ucrania sino
que están dispuestos a hundir al mundo
entero en el Abismo de la guerra
un tono que amenaza con aumentar las
tensiones y reafirma la postura rusa de
cumplir todos sus objetivos en Ucrania a
pesar de la condena internacional por su
parte Ucrania tampoco sede
esto es genocidio a eso nos enfrentamos
hoy si Ucrania se rinde significará que
tales atrocidades se cometerían en todo
nuestro territorio Y estoy convencido de
que cualquier nación representada en
esta sala haría lo mismo nuestro lugar
lucharía
los dos bandos de la guerra miden sus
fuerzas en la ONU Ucrania y sus aliados
esperan profundizar el aislamiento
diplomático a Rusia buscando votos a
favor de casi tres cuartas partes de la
asamblea general